tous les soirs c'est la corvée tous les
soirs vous seul avez tous les soirs
c'est la même chose
pascal assy chante pour les enfants
quarante minutes où ils étaient même
participé ce que j'essaie de transmettre
ses bas c'est vraiment d'être à la
maison on fait un petit spectacle à la
maison que les enfants se sentent bien
que les enfants qui que je fais remonter
sur scène se sentent à l'aise aussi il a
répondu à l'invitation de l'association
rire 78 et son opération rire pour
guérir tous les enfants suivis par le
service pédiatrie ont été conviés avec
leur famille pour ce moment festif
l'action rire pour guérir c'est pour
aller vers les publics empêchés qui
peuvent être comme ici dans un hôpital
mais également maisons de retraite ou
l'ime tous les endroits où les les
résidents n'ont pas accès à la culture
on leur apporte une petite bulle comme
disait pascal assy une petite bulle de
bonheur avec de la musique ou de
l'humour
voilà et parfois aussi des ateliers
c'est une manière de leur dire qu'on se
préoccupe de dans leur ensemble qu'on a
à coeur que malgré la maladie malgré des
pathologies il a une vie agréable qu'ils
aient les plaisirs de la vie comme les
autres enfants une journée d'évasion et
même de lumière pour oman
c'était super chouette j'ai préfet
league mais les d'affaires l'attendait
les blouses roses ont pris le relais
avec une histoire de père noël déjanté
et avait un mais son père noël et un
vent qui père noël
le spectacle comme ça pour les enfants
c'est c'est super sympa ils oublient
voilà il oublie un petit peu la maladie
donc merci à tous à une journée terminée
en beauté avec bien sûr l'arrivée du
père noël en personne qui leur a
distribué des cadeaux